Уряд України кардинально змінив правила надання субсидій на комунальні послуги.
Вже з наступного опалювального сезону
субсидії видаватимуть "живими грошима".
Проте перевірка доходів та матеріального становища тих,
хто претендує на субсидії, буде жорсткішою та прискіпливішою.
Наприклад, відтепер субсидії не зможуть отримувати наступні категорії людей:
Родина, в якої є автомобіль віком менше п’яти років,
крім мопеда.
Власники квартир площею більше ста двадцяти квадратних метрів
та будинків у понад двісті квадратних метрів,
крім дитячих будинків сімейного типу та прийомних родин.
Особи, які здають в оренду квартири.
Окрім того, тепер ці доходи необхідно буде також
вказувати в деклараціях про доходи.
Особи, які є фіктивно безробітними.
Як пояснює уряд, йдеться про людей,
які працюють, офіційно не оформлюючись,
або ж працюють за кордоном.
Особам працездатного віку, які не реєструються як безробітні,
органи соцзахисту відтепер автоматично рахуватимуть дохід
у розмірі трьох прожиткових мінімумів - тобто більше п'яти тисяч гривень.
А тим, хто справді є безробітним,
необхідно буде стати на облік до центру зайнятості.
Нині, за даними уряду, комунальні субсидії
отримують понад шістдесят відсотків домогосподарств.
Торік на це пішло більше шістдесяти мільярдів гривень бюджетних коштів.
За розрахунками чиновників, близько двадцяти відсотків чинних отримувачів субсидії
можуть втратити право на пільги з початку нового опалювального сезону.